hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am thrilled to be
with the filmmakers behind apocalypse
now i'm joking documentary now um i love
this show i'm so happy you guys are in
studio and you guys have like your new
episodes premiering at the toronto
international film festival i have to
say i was a little surprised but at the
same time thrilled did you have any idea
like how did it come about that you were
going to show some episodes here why are
you surprised well you never i mean
no i know because we're not a real [ __ ]
no no because it's mostly it's mostly a
film festival and they do select tv uh
but what had you how did it come about
well i mean and alex can answer this
more fully but we were here in season
one um uh as well not i don't think we
were part of this
it was a screening right it wasn't on
the but part of the documentary program
um so that relationship was there but um
yeah i mean uh
tom powers i think the
the degree to which we enjoy the fantasy
that this these are real documentaries
and this is a real show that's been
going on for 53 seasons um tom powers
who runs the documentary program here at
toronto is also a friend of the show and
he's moderating things for us and just
gets the show as well as anybody does
and so it was a conversation with tom to
say wouldn't it be fun if we just
brought our fresh documentary films to
the festival as if they were part of the
documentary program and you thought that
would sound like a fun idea it feels
absurd though too i'm all in on this
like i love it i'm just you know what i
mean anyway so
one of the things that i'm consistently
blown away on by your series is the fact
that i said this off camera is the fact
that every episode is essentially a
pilot you are not able to reuse anything
it's all new everything including the
aesthetic of how you're going to film
the episode it's not you know the same
camera like it's all different so how
the f do you pull this off every season
with whatever budget you have
uh we i mean it
we
part of it is that
alex and i
grew up that way at snl as well um we
worked in the film unit and
and every week you know something on a
wednesday night um sometimes involving
fred uh we we would make a new film uh
from start to finish and we'd have one
day to figure that out and it would be a
different genre a different aesthetic so
it's definitely that prepared us for it
but um no it's hot it's uh we uh you
know and each season
um we've also sort of traveled each
season as well so had the experience of
kind of introducing a brand new producer
and production team to the way we do
things um which is what also
um
i feel like we take it for granted
somewhat that we're constantly dancing
between styles and what have you but you
know watching it sink into
a new cruise um
brings home kind of
the difficulty of it but i don't know
it's also refreshing and exciting it's
nice that you know you spend a few days
you go all in
figuring an aesthetic out you know
really we're sort of living it and i
think part of the way we make it for
alex and i as part of the fun is
you know like you're sort of mentioning
the different aesthetics we
i feel like we operate a little bit by
taking on the character you have to take
on a character of the filmmaker that
you're referencing or figure one out at
least so you've got some rules in place
um so we get to live it as well
and then um and then yeah you finish
that and you jump on to something
completely new so you don't get time to
also overthink anything which is i think
a plus of that working that way
one of the things i i have to talk about
is the music on this series i i'm
there's so many songs and so much music
and i'm just curious how exactly does it
come together how early are you creating
um and i think about like the episode
with like blue jean committee you know
and like just all the stuff that went on
with that um i i'm very very impressed
i'm just curious if you could talk about
it um once we have the idea
that's kind of like a puzzle piece that
uh
i love figuring out and that we figure
out together so it's like
that one is like 70s uh smooth rock
great
and so we all just
pitch in and just we want it to sound
authentic and not jokey
so that's like the main part of it like
how can we make this sound authentic and
same thing with the um the talking heads
one
same same kind of thing like how can we
make it sound like not jokey and once we
establish that
then we can you know write and record
and and go crazy well specifically on
the talking heads one and i could be
mistaken but i believe you filmed that
in front of like a thousand actual
people yes so what is it like for you
when you're writing the music knowing
you're actually going to perform this or
did you know at the time you were going
to perform in front of all these people
we did know because you know that that
episode is a concert film
and for me it was more like i don't want
it to be something where we've got to
like
fix it later i wanted to sound like a
real because you could always tell but i
wanted it to sound like a real live show
so that was just a matter of rehearsal
we just practiced and practiced until we
sounded like a band that had been
together for
decades that was uh the goal anyway i
mean it really it helps us that fred has
such a great you know just history of
his own in the music world and he
understands what would sound like a real
show and what would not and fred's own
instincts about no no this will sound
fake and this will sound real
is what makes those things feel real
really obviously like everyone i am the
biggest fan of spinal tap um and how
much did you debate doing something
spinal tap e or is it such a masterpiece
that you can't even f with it that's a
that's a
tough one and an easy one because
there's so much respect for it that that
every i think every fake documentary
goes and
asks the question has spinal tap already
done this
and um i've written to them about this
by the way i'm like i cannot believe 40
years later in the writers room we're
like we can't do that because spinal tap
did it
and but it's good that what makes it
easy is it's
we we can't say like no one's going to
notice we can't say you know it's it's
very much like no that is
you know the bible of it all
work around it skip around it go the
other direction and and leave it alone i
was just going to say there's a little
bit of
when
we're trying to figure out what to do
what episodes to do
um
and you know when we talk to people who
also appreciate the show there's
sometimes a instinct of suggesting oh
that that documentary was funny you
should do that one or that documentary
oh that was so you know that had so much
comedy and for us like what tends to
work better is when it's a
character-based documentary that's kind
of more dramatic you know if it's
already funny
it's harder to have like what's our take
on something that would be funny on top
of something that's already funny
so we tend to
to uh probably
not try to take on
a documentary that's already got a bunch
of humor in it you know because what are
our unique original turns on something
that they've already done a really good
job on yeah i mean i'm sorry to continue
this but it's it's a tone thing i think
is the most important thing and i do
think that perhaps an unspoken
thing between all of us
is the because i do find that we all
um tend to back away from anything that
feels like a
um feels like a joke
you know that if you can feel it coming
or if you feel you know like if if
you're signposting it and if it breaks
the reality of these characters as
documentary like that's i feel like
that's always the line that we we really
you know if we're gonna cross it we'll
intentionally go there but it's i do
feel like that's the
the thing that we maybe we don't all say
and i think part of the
strength of you know of mullany and seth
and bill like everybody that writes on
the show is they they can kind of you
know we can always push that line but
you know i think the key of the format
and maybe the spinal tap of it all you
know in terms of influence is like you
you can never betray the reality of of
you know
of whatever this world is that we're
building and so
um
again i don't know what i didn't i had a
reason why that i had a reason to start
that answer but uh yeah it's have a
relationship small time i don't know so
you've done i think in the lat i forget
if it was in the first season or not um
season 50 i'm sorry um if uh
you've done a number of two
arcs have you ever thought about doing
more than a two-episode arc have you
ever thought about doing you know what i
mean like where is that how do you
decide where where
you know we have um
i mean i don't know not not as a group
maybe as much there's been moments we'd
i remember season two no no sorry 51. oh
yeah 51. um no you're right uh
it's season two for me i came on in
season 50. uh
but uh we we talked about yeah maybe
doing you know because
of doing like a serialized story you
know yeah i want to because obviously
netflix is became the netflix became
this sort of peak documentary venue for
bingeable um stories and so i feel like
we there was a moment where we
entertained like oh maybe we did yeah a
full just the whole season is just one
thing and then and then i remember i had
an academic uh
uh sort of idea of like that we would
there would all be separate
documentaries but they'd all add up to
the same story ultimately you know like
that we somehow we've um the same story
through all of them but i don't know how
to do that there was a cool idea this
season that we couldn't crack that was
like
two episodes that would be totally
unrelated but then
some internet sleuth would make a third
documentary that was drawing the
connection between the two yeah and it
was just like that's such a funny idea
maybe we'll tackle that but that's
that's so hard to work so figure out how
you do that so i'm so curious it's been
a few years since you made the last
season
how much were you in that in those years
thinking about ideas how did you
ultimately end up with the seven i
believe it's seven episodes this season
was six
i'm sorry six that you ended up with um
like how does that get figured out and
you know what i mean
i mean it's it
a lot of it's practical
we think like well this this we can
actually accomplish
with the budget with the location a
little bit of that but mostly it's um
something that resonates as being funny
so if it makes us laugh when we're on
these
conference calls or whatever
that's gives it momentum and then we we
keep wanting to work on it and then the
ones that
we are we hit when we hit a brick wall
with something we're like we can't
figure it out
it just disappears
which hap you know
it's
it
happens a bunch
if someone has actually never seen the
show doesn't know anything about it what
is the episode you want them to start
with and why ah that's a good question
wow
it's funny because
you know
people will say oh that's my favorite
episode or that's my favorite episode
and you can always kind of tell oh i say
you're you're a music person and that's
you love the blue jean committee that's
how i judge people
[Laughter]
i don't know why i mean this is just my
answer i do feel like
episode 1 of season 50 something about
the feeling going into it
seemed like the right intro and i i
don't know why you tell my sandy passage
yeah i i don't know why i don't know
what it is maybe it was like the mood we
were in
but it was it was just like yeah yeah
yeah that's the one with you and bill as
uh the sisters yeah yeah i mean mother
daughter i'm sorry yeah yeah i don't
know what it is something about it did
feel a little bit like
like was you know a beginning i don't
know why i think it signals what we
because that was actually the one that
kind of unlocked what the show was going
to be because we didn't really know i
remember we sort of had met
for a writer's room you know we spent a
week and i remember we were talking
around all sorts of ideas and it wasn't
until i think seth brought up grey
gardens and and we started pitching
around ideas of it that the notion of
actually taking an existing documentary
and
and basically sort of re-uh remaking it
uh with a twist
that's where that solidified was on that
episode so that's pretty good one what
do you want to tease fans about the
upcoming season
i mean the first of all it's we shot the
whole thing in the uk
so it's a sort of uh
a european
take on documentary now so they're
they're all european films they're
looking at the
broader world of documentary filmmakers
you know previously all of our films
were sort of more you know
north american-centric and
this was more looking at herzog and
agnes varda and you know like the can i
if you don't mind me interrupting was
the decision to film in the uk
during did you realize early on like
there's a tax incentive let's write for
the uk or it was we're gonna is this
guy's idea
i was just selfish i've never shot in
the uk i'm from the uk and i've never
shot there sorry i'm sorry for
interrupting that reese's well she
wanted to shoot in wales yeah no no
actually truthfully
k so and this is the biggest name drop
that we'll do but um you know kate
blanchett did season two with us and um
so she actually brought an idea to us
uh
which was um three salons by the seaside
uh which is a bbc sort of like a 45
minute documentary
um that she brought to us and you know
said take a look at this um this could
be good and so yeah that was very
clearly very regional and very british
and and just felt you know and if if
kate blanchett brings an episode to you
you sort of feels like you probably
should do it um
so that was what definitely pointed us
in that direction but in terms of doing
the whole season there yeah it just i
don't know if it also felt exciting to
me just that it would force us all to
think differently um that it would give
a different landscape of what we could
do and and you know maybe energize the
writing and and and everything and so
yeah i don't know and then yeah i got to
make we made a couple of episodes in
wales which
was just the realization of a
child's dream
[Laughter]
do you is it one of these things because
it's so yeah it's so um
so the show is so critically success
it's you know it's it's uh it gets great
reviews is it one of these things where
the network has sort of said like do you
have to ask for the green light each
year do they've already asked you to do
more for later like how does that
actually work
it feels a little bit like
guys when are you coming up with you
know new season we're like we're getting
it together we're really trying like
okay because you know we've got a new
you know
news we've been really lucky does that
sound right like it's kind of it's a
little bit like we have a really lucky
fortunate partner in you know i've seen
that they've been really patient with us
they you know the the the offers i mean
i don't know any shows that get to just
kind of we disappear for a few years and
then get to go oh you know what we think
we could do another one and we can come
back and do it um so yeah it's it's it's
a combination of of the request being
there but also
um yeah our will to do it but
yeah i don't know again i i'm i'm amazed
that we get to make this show well you
get to make it because the show is
awesome
very kind of you yeah that's very nice
please it's easy to say i mean you know
what i mean um i have to wrap with you
but i have to ask you an individual
question if you don't mind i'm a fan of
when you do voices uh and um you've done
a lot of voice over work and um i did
notice that you are voicing cranky kong
in the super mario upcoming movie yeah
um what exactly goes into preparing the
voice of cranky kong
i think
from
from what i remember
i think they were like
they just told me
you can't talk about it yet
so i was like i think people know about
it already
but for some reason i think it's a it's
very like
they're being very like
we'll let you know oh so there's like a
time i can't even say anything yeah and
not in any harsh tones or like because
it's come up people wanted to ask about
it and i think it's it's like i'm
supposed to wait until
we're doing i will not pressure you
anymore i did not realize that
i finally hit the nerve i'm like yeah
cranky kong was where i couldn't go yeah
i've never seen fred shut down an
interview like that's so funny because
it is not in my nature it'd probably
be easier for me to say like this is
what i did but i do remember getting a
note of like not yet sure i'll just say
that i uh also if people have not seen
big mouth uh perhaps they should oh yeah
to say like that yeah just throwing it
anyway listen i just want to say a
sincere um
thank you for the hard work you put in
to make this show it is so good i really
hope anyone who's not seen documentary
now uh tunes in it's [ __ ] good uh
sorry for the language we appreciate it
thank you and have a great tif thank you
so much thank you thanks so much thanks
for having us
you